-This is very exciting
that you're doing a tour.
It's been a long time since
you've been out on the road.
-Seven years.
-Seven years. And this is nice.
The show is a little bit
about your upbringing,
who you were
when you were young.
And is this true? You were
a great lover of nature
from a very young age.
-My first love.
Probably like 5, 6, 7,
I was out foraging and trying
to, you know, work things out.
[ Laughs ] I tell a lot
of stories in the show,
teal stories about me
and my family and my upbringing
and the state of the world.
This one isn't in the show,
but that just
reminded me of one.
When I was about --
I've got older brothers
and sisters, okay?
So when I was about 8, I got
two brothers and a sister.
My sister,
she must have been about 20.
-That's a big gap. 20 and 8.
-It is a big gap.
In fact,
it goes 11, 13, 14...
I remember when I was about 12,
I asked my mum,
"Why are my brothers and sisters
so much older than me?"
And she just said,
"You were a mistake."
[ Laughter ]
A lot of honesty.
Lots of honesty in my family.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-So, I'm out,
and my sister and her husband
took me out in the woods.
And I always loved finding
things and looking for lizards.
And I found this perfect
shed snakeskin,
and it was beautiful, right?
And I held up, and I realized
my sister was terrified of it.
She was going, "Put it down.
Put it down. It's got germs."
And I started
chasing her with it,
and she was going,
"Put it down."
And she was sort of laughing.
"You're not going to
come in the car, right?"
So I left it there.
And then years later,
I was about 14.
I had some friends around,
and I was teasing her.
I was saying to her --
Showing off.
"Oh, I used to scare her. She
was terrified of a snakeskin."
And she chose
that moment to tell me
that actually
I had been running around
with a used condom.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-That's great.
I really --
I'm so impressed
that she waited --
I mean, she really --
That's like a kill shot.
She had it in her back pocket,
waiting.
-Yeah.
Well, I suppose she thought --
She didn't want to talk about
what a condom was.
But as I was winding her up,
she thought,
"No. Now's the time.
-Yeah.
This -- You want to do this?
You want a piece of me?"
[ Laughter ]
-This love of nature
has continued.
You recently posted
these photos.
You saved a squirrel's life.
-It was a little -- I would do
anything for animals.
I found this little
baby squirrel.
It was --
We live near a graveyard,
and he was out in the road
and he was sort of dazed,
a little bit injured.
And I thought, "Aww."
And he was so tiny.
And you can't -- You mustn't
really take them from the wild.
And the RSPCA don't really care
for wild animals like that.
They say, "Leave it there.
The parents might be around."
So I went and sat with it in the
graveyard for like two hours.
My girlfriend ran home
and got some nuts, right,
which I was chewing up and
feeding it like a little pup
because it was like --
And then we found --
On the Internet, we found
it liked strawberries.
So we went and got
some strawberries.
-And here you are
feeding it a strawberry.
-A little strawberry.
It was --
And then he went asleep
in my hood.
And I didn't move,
and I was there --
And after about
three or four hours,
he sort of perked up and he
sort of jumped on the thing...
He was looking at me,
and we sort of left him.
And probably eaten by a cat
straight after, but...
But, you know --
-Again, there's something --
If he got eaten by a cat,
he never had a better meal.
-Yeah. And nor did the cat.
The cat goes, "This one
tastes of strawberries!
This is amazing!
I want strawberries!"
-And then the cat
was telling his cats,
"You know where squirrels
are great? The graveyard.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-You got to go to the graveyard.
They have nutty,
strawberry squirrels."
-I don't want to think
it was his last meal.
'Cause that sort of --
That always stresses me out.
You know, on, like, death row,
they give you a last meal.
They say, "What do you want
for the last meal?"
I'd say,
"I'm not hungry, to be honest."
I mean, the stress of --
How could you enjoy it?
I'd say, "Are there nuts
in this? 'Cause that's...
This is gluten-free, isn't it?"
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
The funny thing is my whole life
people have told me you
have to chew your food more.
-Why? Do you eat like a dog?
You just swallow it?
What do you mean?
-Well, you know, you're supposed
to chew your food like 50 times.
-I do, yeah. I know.
I gulp it down.
-But that would be the meal
where I would just be
chewing the [bleep] out of it.
Just like...
-Yeah.
-Just really making it last.
I don't think
that would work, though.
After a few days,
they'd probably go,
"You're making this last,
aren't you?"
-Yeah. "This is more
than enough chewing."